this weekend marks the 30th anniversary
of the dramatic closing days of the
Apollo 13 mission when the astronauts
were forced to abort their moon mission
after encountering potentially fatal
technical problems two days after
liftoff a slight director for Apollo 13
Gene Kranz helped the three astronauts
return safely to earth now from
Washington DC mr. Krantz discusses his
role in that rescue as well as his work
on many other space missions his
comments last about 35 minutes well our
author today has played an integral part
in America's manned spaceflight program
from the primitive technology of the
mercury-redstone rockets to the historic
Apollo mission landings his engineering
organizational and leadership skills set
the highest standard of inspired
teamwork in overcoming the complexity
and dangers of spaceflight in one of
mission controls finest hours his white
team and provides the procedures that
brought the crippled Apollo 13
spacecraft safely back from lunar orbit
that standard of excellence isn't
calculus encapsulated in the title of
his book failure is not an option please
join me in welcoming former flight
director and head of NASA mission
operations mr. Gene Kranz I'd like to
thank you today for the opportunity to
speak and also to some extent tribute a
tribute to some of the flight
controllers that I've worked with in the
Washington area throughout my entire
career is a microphone working that's
just for TV okay okay this just for TV
okay but they you know it was 30 years
ago today when I was just finishing my
first shift on the pollow 13 and we had
no indication of what was going to come
in the next several hours but in Mission
Control what a crewman calls is Jim
Lovell did hey houston we got a problem
teams of Mission Control are ready and
the tools that we use to contain the
risks in our business or leadership
trust
teamwork and values leadership provides
a focus on the objective and builds a
momentum to achieve it a trust allows
you to make every second count and to
find opportunities that you have never
believed existed values create the heart
within the team to overcome whatever
difficulties are going to face and
values literally create a chemistry such
that communications in Mission Control
are virtually intuitive and teamwork
assures our ultimate victory you know
when we started in 1960 and 61 our world
was vastly different our country was
torn by the escalating conflict in
Vietnam and that decade we had three
political assassinations and the civil
rights movement was just starting within
the nation the cold war with Russia
guided every aspect of our foreign
policy and it was the basic rationale or
the stimulus for the space program
computers existed only in laboratories
are there no global communications and
students in that decade would ride in
the campuses and then in 1961 a young
brash and articulate president John at
Kennedy gave us a dream he said we
choose to go to the moon we choose to go
to the moon in this decade and do other
things not because they are easy but
because they are hard and he made this
statement before we had ever placed an
American in orbit so engineers and
people experienced in flight test in a
small group 31 Canadians and Englishmen
of whom John Hodge here was one of the
members of this Avro Arrow crackerjack
team came to Langley field in Virginia
and our goal was simply to place
American in space our boss was Walt
Williams he's the toughest man I've ever
known he's a brawler he is more fitted
to working as a longshoreman on the
docks in New York or LA than leading the
American space program but Walt was
already a legend in the area of aircraft
flight test in 1947 with the x1 rocket
ship of which he was the project
engineer he took America into the age of
supersonic flight Anna Williams deputy
was appropriately named Christopher
Columbus craft a sort of a prophetic
name given a child at birth and Chris
was the pioneer at Mission Control he
launched each one of the mercury
missions and he was the mentor is that
he was one of the mentors or the
teachers the tutors
brought along this first generation of
young people that are known as mission
controllers
you know mercury control did not have a
single computer there are only three
computers supporting all of Mission
Operations for Project Mercury two of
these word Goddard Space Flight Center
in Greenbelt Maryland very low serial
numbers of the IBM 709 o series the
first solid-state machines produced by
IBM and over in John Hodges Island they
put a vacuum to model one of the 709
series over there and we always launched
eastward over the island so should if we
lost communications in parts like we had
a team in place that would tell us what
to do when the engines shut down our
global communications didn't exist so
with only a few weeks training we sent
young men to 13 tracking stations around
the world they went into the heart of
Africa they wanted into Zanzibar and
Australian ships at sea and islands in
the Pacific sites that were literally at
the ends of the earth and there's to
these young people is very high because
this was the end of the European
colonial era the controllers at Zanzibar
would routinely go to work under the
guidance of the Queen's we're all rifles
or Gordon Highlander regiment and we
never anchored in Port when we went into
ports and South America cities in South
America we always anchored offshore
because we're worried about people
mining and sinking our ships but the
young people at the tracking stations
were the eyes ears and voices spacecraft
passing overhead and for their age they
were given incredible responsibilities
and they grew to be the leaders that we
used in project Apollo I first started
in space in Project Mercury and as John
can testify each one of our launches as
a chapter in the history book of Space
Flight our mistakes were violent they
were brutal they were visible
the first Atlas we launched exploded the
third Atlas we launched was destroyed by
ring safety it always climb vertically
over the launch pad we went to launch
our first redstone rocket we sent the
firing command the engines ignited it
lifted off the pad the engines shut down
the escape tower fired one up to an
altitude of about four thousand feet
they told the people in the viewing
stands to run for cover the booster
engineers were speaking in German down
there
we
understand what they were saying and we
literally did not know what to do but we
were fortunate in those days because our
nation understood there is no
achievement without risk and there
certainly ordered any guarantees in this
new business that was called space light
I put six Americans in space in our
first two years never close calls and
each one of those missions especially in
John Glenn's and Scottie carpenter's
mission but we got every one of our crew
members back so by the time that we'd
finished Mercury we had Liv learned that
man could live in space but we learn
much more we learned of leadership
leaders must have integrity they must
accept risk and they must never pass on
any uncertainty to their people
we also learned a lot about ourselves
because many of us came in from aircraft
like tests and our egos was at least as
big as Olsen's here today but we learned
to check our ego at the door and we
became a team and by the time that we
had faced Mercury we were a superb team
so I moved into the Gemini program and
Gemini was designed to develop and test
and prove the technologies that we
needed to go to the moon one of these
technologies was associated with our
mission design our trajectory design now
in Project Mercury we had two very large
groups of women about a hundred number
that was called the math physics branch
and we gave them manual calculators and
they punch away at these keys and the
numbers would spin they'd write the
answer down they plot a graph paper and
they would do this endlessly day after
day just for a single Mercury mission
well this wasn't going to get us to the
moon it wouldn't even get two
spacecrafts round of it in Gemini so
they finally gave us computers in each
one of these machines was as big as a
room five of them filled the entire
first floor in Mission Control and they
even put a small computer on board the
spacecraft but the problem was we had no
computer experience so I went to the
colleges and universities and brought in
the young people who are now graduating
as part of the national student defense
loan program first generation of young
people educated in computers we brought
them into Mission Control and we merge
them with Mercury veterans and we
started working in the very edge of all
knowledge all technology and all
experience
the Russians had about a
two-and-a-half-year lead on us and we
started but one had white stepped
outside of a spacecraft on the Gemini 4
mission we had now narrowed that lead
down to mere months and then on the next
two missions for the first time we set
American spaceflight records first for
mission duration and then we rendezvous
to space grass and by the time that we
had finished the Gemini program we had
developed the technologies and the
confidence to continue moving further in
the space but we also continued to learn
about ourselves we learned discipline an
absolute and unwavering focus upon an
objective nothing nothing must ever
compromise the mission we also learned
the value of high morale because we
found we succeeded because we believed
so strongly in our mission our team and
in ourselves so we moved into the Apollo
program and we're on the consoles
Friday afternoon January 27 1967 John
Hodge was one of the controllers in
Mission Control it was our first test of
an Apollo spacecraft we were one month
from launch and our crew members were
Gus Grissom Midway project Chaffee and
we had worked with Gus and hid in the
mercury and Gemini program and Roger was
a rookie preparing for his first
spaceflight mission and the test that
day hadn't been going very well we had
numerous problems and communications and
life-support and deviations to test
procedure they'd call a hold mcountdown
and they'd write up the new test
procedure and then they'd resume the
count and at 5:31 that evening in
Houston control teams were startled by
cries coming from the spacecraft and
they listened to these cries for the 12
seconds it took our crew to die and with
death came anger anger their selves
because in one many ways we were
responsible for America's first space
disaster we were two words into our
vocabulary and Mission Control tough and
competent tough meaning we'll never get
shirk from our responsibilities we are
forever accountable for what we do or
what we fail to do competent we'll never
stop learning we'll never going to take
anything for granted
Mission Control will literally be
perfect we designed the badge the emblem
of the mission controllers you see it in
the book it's on my lapel and this
became the price for admission to
our ranks discipline morale competence
commitment teamwork we would never fail
again Mission Control
the boss is the flight directory is a
one sentence long Job Description
the flight director may take any action
necessary for crew safety and mission
success during the course of a mission
there is no higher authority and the
flight director is supported by a team
of between 15 and 21 controllers there
people who specialize in spacecraft
systems and trajectory operators and we
have flight designers procedures writers
facility operators medical doctor and
and a astronaut who serves as a
principal communications link between
the ground team and the crew and mission
controllers are young they're generally
in their early to the mid 20s and the
flight directors of that era were
generally in their early to the mid 30
and it was amazing it was a team every
age 26 that took our country to the
surface of the Moon in July 1969 and we
literally fought every step of the way
to get there
and when we finally shut those engines
down and the lunar surface we had only
17 seconds of fuel remaining but we had
fulfilled the pledge that we had made to
our now did President John F Kennedy
then we launched again this time in
November Apollo 12 and is a rocket lift
the launch pad were struck twice by
lightning and I had three crewmen inside
a dead spacecraft hurtling up towards
orbit and again we had a two-minute
window of opportunity to save that
mission the young man by the name of
John Aron a preacher mother and a
rancher father came to the Aden Mission
Control made the single call to the crew
that would restore the instrumentation
on the spacecraft they switched in the
backup power supply to the signal
conditioning system with that back the
remaining controllers could now voice up
the instructions to bring the fuel cells
back online secure the navigation system
we got the crew safely to orbit Apollo
13
you've heard the story of Apollo 13 and
there's very little that I can a lot use
to elaborate on that
except it was a magnificent team effort
and it was team from the instant we got
that call until the time that the crew
splashed down and was put on board the
aircraft carrier
Apollo 14 is interesting and was very
interesting to write about because so
few people knew how close that mission
was to not landing in the moon because I
had a young controller with an emetic
person who was sitting the console there
and at the very last moment as the crew
is in preparation for the decent he
noticed his abort light come on and
again for very markov more remarkable
feat of memory he remembered a NASA
Alert bulletin that in a year previous
had talked about a contaminated switches
and he had the crew wrapped on the
instrument panel next to where that
abort switch was and the abort
indication one away now if this had come
up during the process of descent the
engines would have throttled up we were
to switch computer modes from landing
mode to a ascent
rendezvous mode and at the appropriate
time we would have gone through a fire
in the hole' staging this would have
certainly terminated the lunar landing
but in the two hour period of time that
came up with the idea of building a
software patch he voiced this up to
Gerry Griffin who is the flight director
at that time Griffin said okay we're
going to go on the lunar landing and
then MIT came in and improved that
software patch there's a crew is
descending to the surface two hours
later they are executing a 17 step
procedure to first of all bypass that
abort switched while the engine was
throttling up the solder balls settled
in the backend of it now with the solder
ball firmly anchored by the acceleration
they proceeded re-enable the guidance
bring the systems back online at center
so the story of Mission Control I find
is an incredible story of humans ability
to adapt and to improvise given the fact
that they are properly led they trust
each other they've got a strong set of
values or a work ethic that binds them
together when things get tough then you
can form a team and with the team you
can do literally anything so that's to a
great extent the the story of my book
and Mission Control sorry about these
guys John Hodge Harold Miller he was one
of the Sims he was one of these
starry-eyed kids that came in I think
was from Tennessee wasn't okay from
Tennessee
to learn about computers and use of
training yeah
if here we got one of my guidance
officers I happen to be sitting the
console at the time of the lunar landing
grandpa's back there we got Charlie
tringale
now the gentleman who was writing the
procedures during the time of the Apollo
mission
we got Ron buffer was a buffer buffer
buffer back there who was working I
believe in security at that time isn't
that the truth
this is sort of a reunion as I go around
the country I try to round up the people
who live this magnificent story and try
to bring them in here because these were
the people who made it all happen and
that's why I'm really proud to have
these guys with me today questions okay
here we go over here did you stumble
losing the last column screw with a
toxic gas cap the Apollo capsule
oh you're talking the this air was a
really tough on deke Slayton in
particular because they had a procedural
problem and they opened the vent valve
prematurely while they were still
dumping the propellants it was I would
say very difficult concern you'd have
there would be lung damage and I think
that was basically it
yeah I think the medical community
responded very quickly once they
recognize they've been exposed to the
propellants yeah okay
others go ahead Oh after it was Ed
Harris infection of you in Apollo 13 and
were you pleased with Morris I think I
was pleased with his performance because
that depicted the role of the flight
director is the place where the buck
stops as I said to take an action
necessary for crew safety and mission
success personally I believe he is a bit
hyperactive because he had said he had
he had to be that way because in Mission
Control you know you look at the people
working around there they're huddling
around consoles and you would really not
get the feeling that you had a real
crisis a survival situation in hand I
think he had to do that basically to
convey to the public that we got a crew
in serious problems here from a
standpoint of
movie everything that was in there was
technically one of the problems that we
faced during the mission we had many
other problems that they weren't able to
depict her put in the movie a couple of
the technical errors we didn't use
computers to solve the electrical power
management problem that was basically a
series of desktop calculations we used
the computers really to prove that the
procedures were properly integrated and
ready to be voiced up to the crew I also
the Grumman contractor they portray is
sort of a not too much on board as a
member of the team that didn't happen
the everybody that worked that mission
knew this crew had to come home and they
gave it their best okay here we go go
ahead you still have your book my family
or yeah which was it was interesting I
think are you referring to the pictures
that we used to have of the various
controllers around the world Chris Kraft
it was not as close to the controllers
as maybe John and I were because we
lived with them used to have a picture
taken of every controller out at the
sites around the world so that when the
time came up to be at that site he could
look at this guy and he could you know
suck the the metal framework but John
and I lived and basically the same area
and knew each one of these guys very
closer very intimately go ahead any
others here go ahead sleep she gets
through the last four days fellas right
I get I get that question a lot I do
remember that once we had voiced up this
is about 24 hours after the explosion
we'd voiced up the instructions we
performs a maneuver to accelerate the
return journey I had my team take about
six hours off and that was the last time
I remember any any what I would say is
as a sleep or rest period from then on
each individual would take it when they
felt they had a break I used to sleep in
the viewing room and it was it was as
cold as a meat locker up there an idea
to sit in the third floor if nothing was
going on or down on the second floor and
that way you're always accessible but
man at that stage of the game you could
snooze we also
had some sleeping quarters in Mission
Control but anybody who's been in the
military knows they have these metal
lockers that you can slam it sir like
you have in high school and all somebody
did is have to have one of those lockers
you know stuck closed any DNA to apply
and that wake everybody up so we didn't
sleep there too much any others here we
go did your wife understand why you were
so there all the time did oh yeah yeah
my wife was standing right back there
Marta she she understood the business we
lived when we first moved into the space
Task Group we had a relatively young
group so we got to know each other when
we moved into the Houston area we
actually brought in about twelve
families into the same area that became
known as flight controller alie so the
wives knew the job that we did and were
really great we had six kids and Marta
always managed to corral him and keep
him quiet when it was time for me to get
some snooze time go ahead what advice
would you have to future of America's
speaker and they in the book I really a
list four things I'd like to see done
the first thing is the Apollo program
and going to the moon was almost an
anomaly it was an artifact of the Cold
War we had a young new president who had
been embarrassed by the Bay of Pigs who
was enamored by the image of these
astronauts in the Alan Shepard etc so it
was literally I think a gift to our
generation I don't think we're going to
see that gift at least any time in the
near future because you need a very
strong leadership component and you need
a country behind you and a book I really
say that
anybody who has ever worked in dreamed
of or as an alumni a space has to really
become what I'd say infantryman
foot soldiers in this battle we must
become heard we must have some of the
technical associations stand up and
instead of talking to NASA and the
technical groups let's start talking to
the American public let's start talking
to rotary in the Kiwanis
and the chambers of commerce because we
have to build this mandate ourselves it
isn't going to be given to us that's the
first thing and I think that's that's a
doable thing I think that architecture
is there what we need to do is we need a
leader who's going to start pulling this
group together second thing we really
need to do is we need to revitalize NASA
NASA has gone through I think a very
difficult period of time in the 10 years
last 10 years because they they've sort
of subscribed a lot of fantage faddish
management techniques they flattened
organizations they rear connected
organizations everybody's been TQM to
death but the fact was is that we lost
much of the middle management ground
where leaders are developed as a result
of that they moved into a consensus
driven organization and and we lost that
ability to train young new managers
second thing third thing third thing we
got to do is I think it's time for some
new leadership at NASA I believe that
we've got an individual in there who
really has not looked after the what I'd
say the full range of interest of the
agency and we focused too much in the
political aspects of the job a fourth
thing we got to do is we got to
re-engage Congress and there I really
think that also is looking for a new
administrator leader very similar to the
early ones who are the Masters of the
political process and builders of
support alliances so really we got a
four step process but the first one has
to be to build this mandate and it isn't
going to happen unless we get in the
trenches can cause attack here we go by
aligning ourselves with Russia and we
sacrifice safety for economic teams
and certainly the astronauts keep
interesting back to the mere question of
safety of the entire Russian vti at the
time of my departure from NASA I had
written a letter to the administrator in
the topic of safety and I believe that
we have a different set of standards
that we use within our program in the
design of our systems and that they use
but I believe the real safety standards
that are necessary for a space station
or something of a compromise between the
two the Russians do have a lot of
experience in space and I believe it is
maybe appropriate for us to really look
into those things that we should impose
upon our system engineering process I
believe that the real real problem we
got that is compromise the safety is not
the design standards but the fact is
that people don't speak up I think when
they should I believe basically we have
a NASA today where people feel unable to
step forward to their boss and say I
think we got a problem and have a boss
that says let's look into it and again I
think that was the key to our real
success during the Apollo program wait
back there any emissions coming up and
exporting years worth future will not be
enough I believe every I believe that's
true on every mission you know when you
strap you and being some type of about
six million pounds of rocket propellant
that's not a very conservative a
business to assign up for and your
systems has to be perfect your reactions
your response has to be perfect right on
on the line I think every time we launch
failure is not an option
and my concern is is that if we ever do
have another failure we may lose the
full-blown support of the American
public we may really lose our courage as
Americans to continue to be pioneers and
move forward and to really chart the
uncharted areas my concern is we look
turned inward and we'd go through a lot
of soul-searching just like we did after
the Challenger accident I think we
almost lost our program right then my
concern is is the American public and
having an articulator if we have an
accident
to step out and say this is why it is
important we continue to move forward
go ahead thank you with mistakes cancel
50 I think it was actually 18 19 and 20
I sure hate to see all that beautiful
space hardware static displays at
Kennedy Marshall and Houston I think we
could we have much work we could have
done to me the real mistake was shutting
down skyline because there I think we
had an awful lot going for us and I
think we could have been well up in the
learning curve for extremely long
duration missions because the Skylab was
the world's truly first Space Station
and it was the most productive system go
ahead Renato so who is what oh my that
would be that'd be tough to say because
I have to give a bunch of my worked an
awful lot with Charlie did if I would
sit in the book I say that I think
Charlie Duke was probably the guy that
was closest I would have been able to I
think very rapidly bring on and make a
flight director out of the guy Charlie
just had it all together as an astronaut
as a controller as a leader as an
articulator he just had all of these I
really like him but there are a lot of
them that are out there
I like hoot Gibson yeah it's really
tough to say because at least this is a
different breed of person these are guys
that really stand 10 feet tall okay
couple more
what advice is you give to students too
much the following
oh boy yeah it's there's variety thinks
and I used to do a Leadership Program at
NASA
it's obviously you got to get a good
foundation in education but when I was
talking to the kids growing up in my
organization and the other organizations
around nice I talked about really how I
grew up I had great mentors and teachers
every person I ever worked with I
learned something from from my high
school history teacher to the guy who
taught me to fly my boss an aircraft
flight test John Hodge Chris Kraft Walt
Williams I mean you name it it's really
study those things that allow these
persons to be successful encapsulate it
and bring it into your personality and I
had this piece from over here until
you've build a composite and it's really
study people and you know don't try to
set a timeline I'm going to be a leader
by didn't but know that I'm not what you
got to do is you'll know when you're
ready and you just hope to god when
you're ready that you have some boss who
lets you try it out too many young
people today never really get the chance
to be a leader because they don't have
bosses who will allow them to lead to
grow up to learn okay one more
comments about any manned missions to
Mars have any thoughts on that I'd love
to see it but again we have to build
this mandate first I I do not think I
was speaking up with Gene Cernan we were
up at Texas A&M about a week ago I think
it was and he really said something that
really intrigued me he said it's almost
like Apollo the program was out of
sequence like John F Kennedy reached
into this next century and grabbed a
decade out and shoved it right in the
middle of our current century you know
and and this was a gift to us and to the
American people and we have to you know
I'd hate them I'd hate to have to stand
up in front of a John F Kennedy they
they and say why we had been marching in
place for the last three decades he had
to be tough to really answer that and
it's mainly because we were
great engineers maybe we could lead a
program but we did not articulate we did
not trust the American public devout and
talked on I've become a real believer of
this talking to the people and it was
only I think I only realized this after
I had left NASA and realized how little
communication that there really is in
the outside we got a we got a group of
people out there who are willing to be
led and start marching in the right
direction if we got the people to give
them that inspiration okay one or two
more questions and then we're going to
punch out here's one back here motion
refers to arms about the Seahawks Ted
explained well I I do see a static
display but yeah it's one thing to have
a Saturn five but what is really I think
T is we abandoned the mission that
caused the Saturn five to happen you
know a Saturn five just sitting there
with no mission to perform is is is
waste so it was really we got to go back
into what was the reason that brought
the Saturn five into existence you know
if I'd say the thing that's been
abandoned
you know we had three pioneering
aircraft companies McDonnell Grumman in
North America and where are they today
you know these were the people who built
South so you go back into the
infrastructure Saturn five great but
what happened to the infrastructure that
build it that's the scary thing to me is
that we no longer have that kind of a
industry out there capable of producing
us said you want to go to Mars we got to
build the industry first to be able to
go to Mars at least when we started in
the 60s we had people who had built
airplanes cranks we're used to the risk
of business okay final question the
International Space Station do you agree
with the
they should take the 30-40 shuttle
missions the parts upper- put bigger
parts on and instead of a launch game
Wow that's sort of a design engineering
you know that's a tough question is to
ask if I were to challenge the
International Space Station it's really
the basic architecture of the system
that establishes the Russian component
as a central node that is I think the
largest problem we have the other one is
is that we put it in an inclination
which in an acts of performance penalty
upon us frankly if I had to start over
again I'd have a whole bunch of small
space stations in the proper orientation
and orbit for the missions that you
wanted to accomplish many of them
unmanned or untended okay I think that's
about it I think we're about ready to
punch out here thank you
hard there's no more out front no more
books out front oh wait cow gang thank
you
[Music]
and one for housing the two L's
yes sir - yeah those are important
features yeah kids still follow all this
all with that yeah
Foxy's yes capabilities and so smart I
know what I told you last time I talked
about it was first graders and all very
smart young man look at the races
how do you feel about black holes get
all I heard were hanging on the
dedication right don't you later -
streets John went it was the same
thankful is disseminate that white fight
and then I'm desi I'm fine there people
get paid or care it's nice with the loop
line
yeah
[Music]
anat I know streamline heart thank you
thank you for everybody all I'm saying
to Steve and thank you very much just
[Music]
that's great David for me that is
today's the anniversary thank you sir
you got it saying thank you yeah just a
- Steve thank you
[Music]
tiny be awesome life to Mike thank you
very much irons and everything equipment
what's that we'd want which is what was
it like to work was one up on Brock John
asked that on there good while I write
so what's good but very smart apparent
in a are are just want to Rachel yeah re
the HDL
runner on over in here don't look stereo
pairs long oh yeah a few books to Connor
Kumari Milo thank you got to hear you
speak last year it's a Denver repair
software company I can think about also
drinks wonderful I'll be in the white
spire it's not to say there are people
who still enjoy space burger that's one
ran through the front
thank you very much I'm Tony what do you
think of the guys are trade you in the
near plane sir
I mostly okay cereza free body
I don't really know found an
Englishman's plan the only ones I really
like I like the one on the Apollo on
fire and I like we're live
it's today's the anniversary of to
animator god potentially thank you
gentlemen
what is a lyrical essence they didn't
have it back you can ever do it going
down there about two weeks sometimes
well as the squadron commander for the
Air Force down oh is that right
we reposition complex fourteens block
out when you go down time you went along
to see it because it's a renovated and
turned into a opportunity laughs awesome
you know Colonel macfay misled
could you put one of them to Rick
gene Kranz was flight director for
Apollo 13 the moon mission that was
aborted due to potentially fatal
technical problems he was awarded a
Presidential Medal of Freedom for his
role in helping the three Apollo
astronauts return safely to earth this
weekend marks the missions 30th
anniversary his book failure is not an
option it is published by Simon &
Schuster